by the way you really are a [ __ ] I mean
III heard you on the wrap-up so I'm
gonna play it where you they're asking
you about who is running for president
politics is not my thing like a [ __ ] are
you stupid I mean do you ever open the
paper ever yeah I open it a little bit
upper rock Obama was a Republican is a
good guy I I think I'm gonna vote for
Obama I really am
he's got to be better than the [ __ ]
we have in the White House now so it's
still a horserace you don't see yeah you
know why she's Clinton's wife what does
she do for a living
she's ha I know what she is she's the
governor of which country of New York
right
she's the governor Pataki do you still
think Pataki's governor no no she's now
who's the governor of New York
she's the governor right and who are the
Senators I mean why should Brownback or
something how many senators if you're
asking for another one we must have two
so Brownback and who else
well I won't call you an idiot if you
get this where you got Brownback right
you know that Hillary Clinton's the
Governor of New York who is the other
senator from New York you'll impress me
if you know that
[Music]
I think I got it he used to be the
District Attorney of New York go ahead
Robert Morgenthau very good you know
when you think you're impressive that's
why I don't do it much so you knew
senator Morgan foul and round and
Brownback and the governor and the
governor uh Clinton I think she I know
she's had something to do with New York
I think she's the governor good well all
right yeah you've impressed me but like
his politics is not my thing it should
be and I have to you got those right I
mean not everyone get any senators are
there total well I'm guessing two two
senators oh no from New York but then
have you probably two per state a
hundred senators voting States you're on
the target there did you ever notice
that everything Sal doesn't know isn't
his thing yeah like being smart is in
this thing yeah you never read the
newspaper being a producers not your
thing you never read the newspaper
nothing I do read the newspaper I read
new 600 right past the first page you
know it's just um this is not CNN Howard
this is the Howard Stern Show you know
this just may be a curious Hannity you
might want to listen to me
I'm glad I didn't vote for Bush and now
nobody can blame me but hey who is the
other guy the other guy could have
[ __ ] up too and then you couldn't
blame he he doesn't vote and he
considers that a good thing cuz he goes
he says on the wrap-up show there's no
difference look how bad the country's
doing so if I voted yes
look look with all the [ __ ] who
voted for how they regret it now I'm
like maybe not voted for the other guy
and we wouldn't have had Bush you could
have saved us well that's all hearsay
we don't know what this guy would have
done thank you and that's why I'm gonna
I'm going to go against the grain I'm
I'm seriously considering voting for
Obama and I do mean that because why
this world has been so screwed up for
the past hundred years why do you like
Obama what is he for he's pro-choice
which I agree with
mmm the guy look if you're a black guy
in America and you can push the people
to vote for you
that's impressive I know and I mean
that I got emotions here well I guess
that's everything it comes out here
about to the stupid alright thank you
sorry
you